好 剛剛我們講到
光學概念這一波超級強
但是不只光通訊
竟然有蘋果的概念
蘋果大家不是不喜歡嗎
怎麼現在喜歡起來了
因為這次的新品發表會
非常不一樣
好 這邊要請教我們的
黃金右下角
趙華好
選古教練為他
因為前面兩個都在講
比較創高的嘛
交給你了
我們要撿便宜
蘋果的秀
其實以前大家都會覺得
會不會了無心意啊什麼的
可是這一次
可能會有遮疊機
然後可能會有一個M6的晶片
這些都會是整個半導體
很重要的事情
包括我們自己有半導體站
右下的還有設備跟特化
可以挖黑嗎
OK 好
9月份其實是這個
電子股或科技股
非常精彩的一個月份
因為呢
首先我們可以觀察到
蘋果的發表會
預計在9月10號
禮拜四的凌晨會登場
那麼這次邀請就像這樣子
有這個驚喜藥線
然後呢
而且主視覺有這個發光蘋果
發光蘋果
光通訊蘋果
有可能
這次這個Google新的手機
也是有一個發光的設計
所以這一次的新機好像
對它有發光比較亮亮的感覺
好 那市場呢
盛銷層上
傳說會推出iPhone 18 Pro系列
還有折疊iPhone
折疊iPhone
這真的是這個千呼萬喚使出來
微胎的手机
有点时间好像没有换的话
还没有换
那你要换折叠机了吗
我其实有在想
我有在想
那我们就看看它接下来
它出来的那个到底规格
到底是如何
那除了苹果之外呢
这个台湾之光
半导体产业
我们的国际半导体展
预计要在9月2号到9月4号
那么这次的半导体展
聚焦在AI的先进封装
Keywords
小晶片
新小期的小
矽光值
量值技術等六大技術版图
所以我才说在9月份
尤其是在9月份上半旬
基本上的电子族群
应该会相当相当的热闹
对 而且呢
大家不要有苹果的消费性电子
因为它在晶片上面
还有包裸我们才一定
2奈米这些事情
对 都很值得留意
对 谢谢赵华帮我开场
好 我們講到說這個折疊機
其實這個之前大概兩年之前
我們就看到有非常多的廠商
尤其是一些中國大陸的廠商
都已經提早做推出
那麼這次呢
據傳這個iPhone的Artra
也是要推出這個所謂的折疊機
那它這次推出折疊機呢
有幾個比較
我覺得比較重要的地方
第一個就是
它所搭載的A20晶片
就是要用到台积电的2奈米
2奈米的一个技术
那相机呢
有48MP的广角跟超广角
而且它是要做什么
极薄的设计
而且是没有长焦
那我们先来看一下
就是在刚刚有提到
就是苹果终于这个
千呼万唤使出来
它折叠手机终于有可能
会在这一次要推出来
那外传的这些
所谓苹果折叠手机的供应链
还有非苹果阵营的
遮掠手機給我幫大家
去做一個對照
首先像最近長很強的
這個台虹
台虹軟版
軟性的CCL
軟版的部分
它有出所謂的
蘋果也有出飛瓶
這張表格
基本上就在找
所謂雙漆的
同時有在出蘋果的
也可以在出飛瓶的
它們好像不只雙漆不是蘋果跟飛瓶很多都切到AI供應鏈去像漆虹 雙鴻那如果說把它共產在一起我們要找一個雙漆的就是這張表格那這些個股呢
基本上我們認為說
他們有一些
就剛剛趙華所提到的
如果說你有吃到
就是說手機以外
就是AI相關的這個
營收的話會比較好
例如說齊鴻
它在今年一到七月的
累積營收成長80.34%
而且股價創歷史新高了
對 OK 好
那其他像是雙紅也創了
也加了83.28%
這些都是有跨出到
所謂AI相關的
但是接下來
因為我不需要講
AI相關的個股有很多
都已經漲一大波了
創下新高了很多
所以反而現在市場上面
給我的感覺是什麼
就是有一些就是
之前比較沒有漲到的
現在開始慢慢慢慢的
會有一些資金
在這邊去做一個佈局
我懂了
因為剛剛我會想說
兵臨城下了
將士要先衝對不對
但是我們要叫後面的人
是 你上
趕快跟進
對 叫後面的人上
好 那在這裡面
特別看到就是說
浴金光的部分
可是這個是創高的
對 是零頭樣
可是說它創高
但是如果說跟這個
所謂大力光相比
我覺得它的漲幅其實還好
是用這種比較法
對 而且剛剛在表格當中
我特別去篩選
就是大戶持股有增加的
因為其實如果你去看這個大力光
它大戶持股其實是往下減少的
那反而郁金光呢
它在这个波段
它的大户持股是往上做增加
甚至投信呢
也开始回头站在买方
所以站在整个筹码面的结构上
我认为它的后续的续航力
可能会比较好
OK
当然啦
不管是郁金光
或者是大力光
短信上面涨多了
出现正乖力过大的时候
我都不建议大家去进行追高
这个是郁金光的部分
那郁金光除了这个
所谓的手机镜头之外
它也是有在布局光通讯
所以我觉得再两个都是
有布局光通讯
有布局这个手机镜头
这两档各个我觉得有拉轨
都可以优先做留意
好 堪称就是光学镜头的大哥跟二哥
所以大哥已经表态了
二哥虽然也创高
但幅度没有那么大
值得留意
对 好
那么除了预金光之外
另外一档我认为是华通
他就比较吃力一些
但今天是涨停表态
对 华通其实在这个
低轨卫星的营收占比
还没有出来之前
它有很大一块的营收
都来自于苹果的手机
可是苹果手机
在过去的成长性
真的就不好
所以就使得
它的滑通曾经一度
它的股价都没有什么表现
那后来它是搭上了
这个低轨卫星
所以它的股价才开始往上冲
冲到三次头的一个价位
但是现在看起来股价
又拉回了耶
又拉回了
最近看起来
它的股价已经从300多块
掉到154块
这几乎是腰斩了
它股灾的时候
连现增价都跌破了
真的很惨
对 但是我个人认为
现在它的一个股价的表现上
有一点点在做头肩底的概念
头肩底
目前看起来是在做右肩
而且右肩有机会往上去多突破
那么在往上做突破的背后
其实就是投信
从原本的一直卖
一直卖一直卖
在最近这个礼拜
几乎天天都在买
是
其实都在买
所以像这个投信浪子回头的这种个股
我觉得基本上有机会
再往上去进行这个走高
OK 再来
除了这个华通之外
另外一档比较低位阶的
还有像成名店
它可能也让投资人比较失望
因为股债的时候是腰斩之外
反弹还弹不太动
对 好
从136到这个70块钱
基本上假设这个45路
140的话就是腰斩
就是腰斩
这波拉回
其实我可以观察到
这波拉回下来的过程当中先不往上做墊高現在看起來也是量縮守在月均线值上那么这个过程当中第一个我们可以观察到外资
外资之前在高档
其实有在做调节
但是现在我们从7月份开始
就看到在外资开始
去做持股回补的动作
同时大户持股的部分
已经连续四周都往上做增加了
所以我觉得目前这些的一个个股
第一个法轮的筹码有在回补
那么股价还在月线跟季线的附近
股价相对比较低
是属于右下角的位置
所以接下来如果说行情有在做轮动
这些族群都可以特别做留意
不过他这边的高档量
跟现在的量差异超级大
应该有两三万张
这边只剩下一千张而已
对 换句话说
这边买进的人都还没有跑
都套在这边
有可能是不想跑
也可能是跑不掉
如果是跑不掉
他就必须要去做一次解套
OK 這個就是成名店
好 相當右下角的股票
OK 好
那看完了這個
剛剛提到了這個Apple
Apple相關的這個連接
那它裡面的這些所謂的
這個新的晶片
反倒是我個人認為
非常感興趣的
真的不要小看Apple
它真的都是先進製程裡面
第一個去跟台移電要單子的
對
它這次用到的就是
最新的先進封裝的一個技術
叫做晶圓級多晶片模組
基本上就是我们在讲
它是属于次世代的
所谓的面板级封装的概念
它有什么差别
就是基本上在过去
我们说像COWAS这种
它是一堆叠在一起的
什么2.5D或3D
但是现在这个所谓晶圆级多
前面模组像这个示意图一样
它是把它平铺在晶圆上面
然后这个平铺在晶圆上面之后
它在这个上面里面
它可以放什么CPU
S-RAM然后记忆体等等
那它的好处就是呢
它没有所谓的中介层
那它这个功耗或成本的部分
都表现得更为优异
所以我觉得接下来
像这种所谓适用在所谓的手机
或者其他的这些所谓小型的
所谓消费性电子产品的部分
都很有可能会用到这个设计
好 所以这个苹果也是在
晶片设计上面不遗余力的
这是可以留意的
虽然很多人说苹果好像切AI比较慢
但是它对于这种效能的研发
是真的蛮厉害的
对 好
换句话说
在苹果带头的情况之下
2奈米接下来就有可能会开始进行放量
是
那2奈米放量有哪些有可能会有机会受惠
我们今天就把一些相关的就是
先进封装的设备
还有一些所谓的特化相关的个股把它列出来
其实应该还有一个族群
就是像旺系
像隐威这种所谓的
所谓探针卡的部分
今天没有再请你来救救旺汐
今天一度又杀到
好像4500块钱附近
但拉上来
好长的下隐线
那这里面呢
其实像是红硕 君华 万润 星云
这一类的
大家有没有觉得
跟之前什么COLAS的这些设备
都好像都重叠
没有错
基本上他们都是
可以去做相关的
所谓的一个产品的出货
所以这部分我觉得
之前大家比较没有提到
或已经忽略到这些一个
所谓的设备个股
可能大家又要开始
再去回头看它
像今天像万论
就是出现掌停板的一个表现
那蒙利也是
今天也出现掌停板的一个表现
所以我觉得接下来这一些
又回到所谓的先进封装
设备的一个族群上
大家可以特别去做留意了
好
那我们之前刚提到
像是富士达的部分
富士达是之前跟大家分享过
那當時我跟大家講說
這個地方有雙腳底對 然後已經衝上來了但是你覺得之後還是看好所以它回測月線以後又上去了又再上一次OK 這個雙指定要說是
投信的浪子回頭
這個地方 果然就是一直回
一直回
再來那個猛利的部分
在之前是目前看
之前是在這相對低檔的地方
那目前看起來
股價也是再度創下這個
破綻性新高
那麼外資跟投信
都同步站在買方
所以我们一直都对盟利很好
因为主要是机器人的代表之外
它还是有切半导体设备
这种我们很喜欢
对 好
那刚刚的表格当中
几档个股我认为是底型比较确立的
是
底档个股是5443的均豪
这地方也是可以观察到
它是这样子下来的嘛
然后这波上去股价是突破它的颈线
突破颈线之后做回撤
那特别是说在这个过程当中
大幅的持股也是往上再做增加的
那接下來相關的這些所謂檢測設備
進入到出貨任列高峰
所以第三機跟第四機
大家可以退位做留意
均豪是均華的母公司
可是股價已經拉到天差地遠之外
它的股性一直都不太好
因為抽馬集中度還是有點差異
均華真的是很集中
我記得一直有它的千張到海
這樣六七十趴
那麼再來就是台特化的部分
你今天挑战的是很多观众的心痛苦
对 为什么会这么讲
因为他其实
因为刚提到
接下来就是2nm相关制程
要开始去做放量
那么之前他们很早就把这些什么
细椅碗或者是细柄碗等等的
这些高阶的所谓的一个特用化
特用气体去做了这些所谓验证
那消息出来的太快
可是真正2nm相关的制程的产量
还没有放大
所以股价先涨了
那漲完之後發現EPS沒出來
那之前這些所謂的驗證所開收來的費用
又要認定在所謂的一個EPS裡面
所以導致它今年上半年
EPS有一塊多而已
但是隨著接下來兩奈米次成的一個放量
我認為它整個營收
有機會會出現所謂的倒式甘蔗的情況
所以接下來Q3跟Q4
可不可以留意這些
股價已經修正過在低檔的
而且有點像是在租
這種所謂的頭肩底的個股
大家可以特別多留意
這就是大家喜歡黃金右下角的原因
因為它很大很大的比例
都是給台積電
所以我們剛剛錄影前也聊了一下說
他幫台積電做這麼多了
怎麼錢不給他賺一下
應該有即將
這個獲利往上跳的機會了
對 倒吃甘蔗
好 倒吃甘蔗送給台特化
大家再有點耐心
這邊非常謝謝維泰
謝謝趙華
好 維泰提醒我們
9月緊接著半導體戰
還有蘋果的新機發表會
這一次的新機發表會
不要忘記了
就很有可能看到所谓的折叠机
这个市场真的是相当的期待
而相关的零组件
现在也受到青睐了
因为镜头也要升级
折叠机用到的材料也更多了
以及所谓的不管是双吃股
甚至是多吃股
因为不只是镜头
可能切到光通讯
切到半导体等等
台厂的科技供应链
真的就是非常的厉害
所以帮您挑到目前为止
还算是黄金右下角
或者是大哥领长
二哥也可能跟长的族群
提供给您其中像设备
其实还蛮多
位阶是相当低的
希望大家都能够从这一波
半导体加苹果的上涨
赚到财富
今天非常谢谢三位雷兵来到现场
今天虽然有点压尾盘
美中部族量能也还没有放出来
但是值得期待我们观察一下
网上的美股
以及这股气势
其实领头羊们都已经
成军在这边等了
能不能接下去接棒呢
大有可为
那也希望今天理财答案秀
最近投资有帮助
明天再会咯
拜拜
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜